The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: So today,
we're doing charcoal making.
And we'll talk a bunch about
charcoal making on Friday,
but hopefully, you read the
directions for making it,
so you're at least
a little familiar.
And so one of the things that's
complicated in charcoal making
is the order of
operations because there
are steps that you need
to do to make briquettes
that, if you want to be most
conservative with your energy,
we need to do while you're doing
the next carbonization burn.
And this is something to
keep in mind if you are
making charcoal in Nicaragua.
Like if you were
doing a demo, you
need to have charcoal
to make briquettes,
and you also need to
be able to do a burn.
So you're actually going to burn
ahead of time in order to make
the briquettes with people as
well as doing the charcoal burn
because it's a
two-step process--
one is lighting your
raw material on fire
and making it into
charcoal fines,
and then the other step
is crushing the charcoal
and mixing with the binder
and making it into briquettes.
But some of those
processes can be parallel.
So the first thing that
we actually need to do
is prepare the cassava,
which is our binder which
is used to keep those
briquettes together.
So this is what
cassava looks like.
It's also known
as yuca or manioc.
I think, in Nicaragua,
it's mostly known as yuca.
AUDIENCE: Yoo-cah.
AMY BANZAERT: Yuca, thank you.
So this is what you look for.
It's generally not waxed when
you buy it outside the United
States, but other than that,
it looks exactly like this.
It's sort of like a
sweet potato in that it
comes much skinnier
and shorter than this
and it comes much bigger too.
So you can find it in
all sorts of varieties.
It doesn't really
matter what you use.
Bigger diameter it's
nicer because you
have more meat to skin ratio,
and you have to peel the skin.
Other than that, it doesn't
matter what you get.
But you should be able to get it
at any supermarket in Nicaragua
and smaller markets
sometimes, depending.
So if you guys want to
start grating this--
peeling it and then grating it,
the peels can go in this bag
and then the grated stuff
can go in this thing.
If we don't have a grater
with you, which you may not,
a spoon works really
well to grate.
It's not as nice as a peeler,
but you can use it to peel.
And [INAUDIBLE] it works
pretty well anywhere.
In terms of graters,
this is probably
what you're used
to seeing, and you
want to use the pointy side.
This is one I
bought in Nicaragua.
This is one we bought in Haiti.
So you can you're going to be
able to find them anywhere.
They're probably not going
to be like OXO brand stuff,
but you'll be able to find them.
So if some percent of
people wants to get
started doing that.
So the other stuff we're
doing is making the charcoal,
making the charcoal fines.
So you can see that this
oil drum has a hole cut out
of the top and about
this big is nice so
that there's enough edge
of the top of the drum
so that when you
put a lid down, you
don't have to be careful to make
it line up to really cover it
well, but big enough that you
can load the material in well.
On the backside, you
just put in a few holes.
We often put in more
holes than just this many,
so I would recommend that.
If I were doing
this drum today, I
would add one here
and here and here.
The holes are for airflow,
and more holes is better.
On the flip side this is getting
to be pretty big in terms
of diameter hole because
you don't want your waste
to all fall out the bottom.
One thing you can do to
manage that, which is in here,
is you can find this stuff,
which is called chicken wire,
and just throw it in
the bottom to prevent
the waste from falling out.
However, you need to have
some waste that comes out
these holes at the bottom.
You'll see that we use
fuses to light the drum.
So it's this weird
catch-22, where
you need it not to
fall out, except you
do so we're not looking to use
this today because the waste
isn't that fine.
The other thing that you can
use chicken wire for-- well,
there's two other
things, but one
is, if you're trying to
carbonize waste that's
pretty small in diameter--
and hopefully you won't be,
because we don't do it well
yet with the current processes.
But if you were going to
carbonize rice husks or sawdust
or something like that, the
method we've come up with
is to take the chicken
wire and roll it
into cylinders that are
about the same diameter
as these holes, put
them in the holes,
and the waste goes around
those holes, but not in it
to help get airflow.
So that's another thing
we use chicken wire for--
and then a third that
I'll show you in a bit.
So the way you make these holes,
if you have an angle grinder,
sweet.
You probably won't,
so you can use
a hammer and a chisel
and sometimes just a nail
to get the hole started.
It's really laborious,
painful to do.
If you can find
someone who you're
working with who's
used to using a chisel
and used to doing
metal work, they'll
do a much better
job than you will,
for at least for most of us who
aren't used to using chisels
on metal most days.
So don't be afraid
to ask for help.
And then when you're
finishing the holes,
down here, you just want
to try to bend them in
as much as possible,
if you can get
pliers or something
similar to bend it
so that no one gets
cut when you're
working with all of this stuff.
It's really easy
to get cut and it's
kind of nasty cut in
a dirty environment.
So it's nice not to have that.
So what we're going to do now
with that awesome warming that
makes me really excited is
to load the raw material
in the drum.
What we're going to try to do is
put layers of the corn stalks,
which is in the
blue tarp, and then
the corncobs, which is
in the green mesh bag,
so if you guys want
to start doing that.
Typically, you would take
if you remember to bring one
on your trip, which you
rarely do in my experience,
you would use one of these to
weigh out how much material you
were using.
In this case, we're not going to
bother with that because we're
just doing a practice
burn and it's cold
and I'm trying to
speed things along.
But generally, for
waste, you're trying
to get about 16 kilograms
into the drum, which is a lot,
so you have to pack it down.
One of my friends likes to
stand on the top of the drum
and sink in when he does it.
But you definitely want
to pack it in pretty well.
So if you guys want to get going
and start loading the drum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: One thing
I forgot to mention,
and it's super easy to forget,
is to put a sniff of any
down the center of the
drum so that the material--
so there's a chimney in
the center to really help
the material to light on fire.
It's two things to know, number
one is really easy for forget,
so try really hard not to.
There are instructions
that you'll
have that go through
each step, and just
make sure to go through them.
The other thing is we've
asked community partners,
do you have a long
stick, and they've
gone out and bought like a
$50 really nice piece of wood
for stuff, when all we need
is any random piece of wood,
metal, you name it will work.
And so just emphasizing
this isn't fancy.
And then as you're
loading, you want
to pull the stick around and
keep making that chimney.
AUDIENCE: Don't-- don't
sink in the fire, man.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: We have done
crazy things like that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: $0.44.
[CHUCKLES]
AMY BANZAERT: OK, so now
what you do is get three--
generally rocks,
but around here,
it's actually easier to
get bricks than rocks,
so we use bricks on campus.
And you want to lift the drum
onto the bricks or rocks.
And the thing is,
once this drum is hot
and on fire, we're going to
have to lift it off the bricks,
and so you want the bricks as
far on the edge as possible
of the drum to make it really
easy to kick the bricks out
of the way.
So if two people want to
lift the drum onto the bricks
and then optimize
brick placement.
So I would pull that
break out further,
and I can't see the other one.
And then you just pull around
to optimize your chimney,
and then pull this out.
So now we're ready to
light it on fire, except--
so that would be
what I would do back
before I've done this a million
times and realized my mistake.
So I said we needed to boil some
water on here for the binder,
right?
So we need to get that ready
before we light on fire.
So it's always important before
you actually light the matches
to make sure you're
completely and truly ready,
both in terms of having
water on the side
so that if there is some
of uncontrollable fire,
you can put it out quickly,
having all the stuff you need
to cover up the drum
when you're done,
having a plan for how
you're going to do that.
So we're going to go
through all of that first,
but one thing we're going to do
is boil water for the binder.
So the way we're
going to do that is
there's going to be two people.
So Kurt, are you going
to help me demonstrate?
Maybe you can just put it down,
maybe a little further away
from the tripod, so we don't--
all right, so we
each take one side.
Sometimes you can wire
it if you're worried,
and then we lift it up
and then you bring it over
and ideally, you'd have a--
the one thing I'm
worried about this one
is that I think the diameter
does not work at all.
So can we put it on the side?
Can you lift it up?
Lift it up.
And then if it goes
there, will it stay?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, but
it has a curved bottom.
So I think we'll go with that.
AUDIENCE: Why can't
we sit it inside?
AMY BANZAERT: Because it's going
to be really hard to take out.
And then do it back.
So Kurt, you've just
gotten practice.
so I want two other
people, one from group O
and one from [INAUDIBLE]
to practice it,
and then you guys will be
the one who actually do it.
But it's actually worth
practicing before you light it
on fire because if you drop
the cold water, you just
destroy the burn, if you
drop it in the raw material,
but if you drop the boiling
water, you can scald people,
including yourselves,
which is highly unideal.
So it's worth practicing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, it might
be the worst chosen pot ever,
so hopefully you will have
more success with pot choosing.
And then you can actually
move this quite a bit
farther away, like to
the edge of the bricks.
This drum is going
to be really hot,
so you won't want to be
near it for too long.
All right, so we're
ready for water boiling.
The other thing I said
we need to be ready for
is covering up the
drum because you
want to do that
relatively quickly,
and the process is one
that's easy to misremember
what order to do it
in, especially for me
because we changed the order
a lot as we optimized it.
So first, what you
do is get the lid on,
which just involves
doing that, and then,
if it didn't quite
get in the right spot,
you can use this to get
it in the right spot.
The other thing you
want to do is notice
if the lid is kind
of convex or concave.
We're trying to make a seal,
so it's better to have--
I mean, it doesn't matter
a lot, but whichever way
fits a little better.
So I think that this way
fits a little better, maybe.
And then we're going to
take it off the bricks.
So for that, what
you do is find--
you do it at the bricks,
so you lean the drum over,
and then someone
comes and kicks it.
And then you very,
very carefully
lower this drum down because
now it's going a bit at angle,
and then you repeat.
There's a shovel around
here that you can also use.
Sometimes it's nice to have
two people manipulating
the drum just for a little
bit of extra safety.
And then once it's all the
way down on the ground,
then we will find something to
cover up this hole, anything
that's around,
and then pour sand
around the edges on the
top and on the bottom.
And just work as quickly
as possible to get it
completely sealed so you can't
see any smoke seeping out
anywhere.
Are there any questions
about all this?
All right, so the one
last thing to know
is, especially when it's
windy, which it often
is in Nicaragua too, it's a
really pain in the butt to use
matches to light this,
but we're going to,
because it's good
to practice that.
AUDIENCE: Where does
the water come in?
The boiling water?
AMY BANZAERT: That's first.
AUDIENCE: We light it
and then boil the water
and then seal it?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, but it's
not a ten second process,
so it'll be plenty of time to
get the water when this time.
So if five people want to
all grab matches and try
to start lighting it,
hopefully we'll have success.
So did you guys all-- everyone
with a match should know,
you're lighting the
bottom at the fuses.
OK, so you guys can start.
AUDIENCE: I don't think--
I think it's going
to [INAUDIBLE] now.
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Exactly, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Wait, hold on.
Are we recording this?
AMY BANZAERT: No, so
what's happening--
[LAUGHTER]
[CLANG]
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
AMY BANZAERT: So
right now, you're
seeing this incredibly nasty
disgusting smoke, right?
And so this is all the
volatiles in the raw material
that we don't want to be
breathing in when you're
cooking inside, burning off.
So you can see there actually
isn't any fire up at the top
when the wind blows it.
The material hasn't actually
lit on fire completely,
so it might not be a bad
idea, if we can do it,
to light some matches
and throw them
in the top to try to
get the topside on fire.
We're not going to be boiling
the water until the smoke blows
away.
At some point, the smoke
will transition to clear.
And when that happens, that's
when we'll do the water.
And this is smoke
that you really
don't want to be
breathing in, if it's not
obvious by the color.
Yeah, if it's too hard,
just don't worry about it
because it's not worth--
AUDIENCE: It looks
like an airplane.
AUDIENCE: Oh, clever.
AUDIENCE: Shit.
AMY BANZAERT: Oh, so
the other thing to know
is that by Cambridge,
Mass law, if we're
going to be lighting a
fire, we have to be cooking.
So there are marshmallows
and English muffins.
Once this smoke clears,
feel free to roast
a marshmallow on whatever
you can find or toast
an English muffin.
And then there's Nutella
to put on English muffins.
So at this point, we can
probably do the water.
So what did you say?
Yeah, it's nice to
use the waste heat.
Nice.
The question of how long to
wait until you cover the drum
is always tricky.
At this point, it's
probably a good time
to cover it which the
water isn't boiled,
but we're just going
to go with that.
So if you guys want
to take the water off.
And then who wants
to throw the lid on?
So can someone grab the shovel?
So the lid is getting
caught into the hole.
And now, who's going
to kick the brick?
AUDIENCE: I will.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
And who wants to
do the next brick?
OK, can someone grab like an
English muffin or whatever
to put in that center hole?
English muffin is way cooler.
We can claim that we're cooking.
And then there's a
whole other bag of sand,
if you guys want to
help get this sealed.
AUDIENCE: And we can
get even closer now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I thought
it's warmer after the fire.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: And you can
obviously use dirt for this.
You don't have to use special
sand that you acquire.
AUDIENCE: So what
was the rationale
for calling [INAUDIBLE]?
AMY BANZAERT: For
when I made the call?
So the flames-- so it's
sort of a time thing
and sort of an experience
thing, but it's
looking at how the quality
of the flame and the flame
started getting really strong,
which means everything is fully
on fire, and if you don't
cover it up quickly,
you're just going to burn
out all your material.
No, so this is all smoke.
This lid is actually
really hard to seal.
In terms of getting
a lid, oftentimes you
can just buy flat pot lids
and that works pretty well.
So when you're buying a
pot, if you need a pot,
if your community partner
needs you to buy a pot,
you can also be
buying a pot lid that
goes over your drum,
this big diameter.
I think that's water,
actually, going off.
We try to seal as
much as possible,
but it's impossible
to do it perfectly.
So that's that, and now
you just wait two hours
and then you come back and the
material should be carbonized.
And if you are impatient and
you open it after an hour,
it'll probably
catch back on fire,
so then you have to just cover
it up again really quickly.
So it's currently
almost 1:00, so that
means we'll be able to
wait almost two hours
and then open it up before a
class is over, which is great.
So next, what I want to do
is light these stoves on fire
so we can make hot chocolate,
and then we'll make briquettes.
When you're making
just a regular charcoal
fire in a developing
country, you can typically
get a special type of wood--
I forget what it's
called in Nicaragua.
I'll try to look it up.
Do you do know?
Is it ocote?
That's what I was
remembering this morning,
but then I was like, oh, I
think that's something else.
OK, so it's called ocote,
and it's basically,
from my understanding, is just
a pine that's really sappy
and this is the equivalent
of that in the US.
And so you light
those on fire and they
help the briquettes, the
charcoal, catch on fire.
This is wood charcoal that I
just bought from Whole Foods
because our charcoal
is so labor intensive
that it pains me to use it
up for something like this.
So if you guys want to
try to those on fire now.
AUDIENCE: So just
like light it like--
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so
those three brown things
are what you're
trying to get lit.
So these are two
different stoves
that we'll be talking
about on Friday.
So the one that Sid and
Misty are lighting right now
is just a really simple
relatively simple charcoal
stove.
I forget what country it's
from, but you can find them
all over the place.
And so it has very little
insulation, obviously.
The one that Kurt
and is that Juan?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AMY BANZAERT: --are lighting
is called a gecko stove,
and we'll talk about
it a bit, but it's
a well-designed
stove that actually
has some decent insulation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what
would be used as a match.
Maybe like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: It's just that
the way they're designed to work
is like this on top.
AUDIENCE: It's just
like getting black.
AUDIENCE: It's getting gray.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's like cold.
I just put it on.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
have much air.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is it yellow?
AUDIENCE: It smells really good.
AUDIENCE: That's how
they always burn.
AUDIENCE: It's definitely, like,
very marshmallowy in the rest
of it, though.
AMY BANZAERT: So after
the carbonization is done,
the next step is to take all
the charcoal fines out and crush
them.
And so this is actually
mostly crushed,
and it's this mishmash of stuff.
But there's some good
examples in here.
So you'll see some stuff
that's just dark brown but not
actually black, and this you
should toss because it's not
fully carbonized enough, and
so it'll make really bad, smoky
briquettes.
Similar-- like this corncob
is not fully carbonized.
With regular corncobs, one thing
to check if they look black
on the outside just
break them apart
and make sure they're
black on the inside.
When you look in
the drum, you're
going to see three things.
You're going to see,
hopefully, majority
is black material like this,
except not in the crushed form
that you see down
below; some that'll
be that brown stuff
that's undercarbonized;
and some that'll
be gray and ashy.
That's over carbonized.
And so if you have
a ton of gray ash
that means you had let
the fire go too long
you should have
covered it up earlier.
If you have a ton that's
on the brown side,
you didn't let it go far enough.
If you have mostly black
with a little bit of each,
that's a good indicator
that you had a good burn.
You're never going to
get perfect 100% all even
because this is not
exactly a high tech kiln,
and so you're not going to
get even temperature flow
throughout the whole thing.
Some of the things on the
form that you fill out
when you do a
charcoal burn, which
I haven't been
doing because it's
too hard to talk and
remember to fill this out,
are things like air
temperature and humidity,
which you probably won't
have a sensor for that,
but if you happen to
know, you can record it.
And otherwise, by
recording the location,
we can look it up afterwards.
So just fill all these things
out as well as you can,
but there are
probably going to be
some things you can't recall.
But especially if you
bring any charcoal back
for testing in the lab,
it's really helpful
to have filled these out.
And then there's one
side that's the form,
and then the other side has the
directions, both what you need
and then what to do.
So hopefully that's enough to
get you successfully making
charcoal.
So anyway, to crush the
briquettes or the fines
into powder, what
we typically do
is load it into two rice bags.
And rice bags are
pretty ubiquitous.
You can get them
almost anywhere.
And then you just
jump on the bags.
When you're done,
you get a mixture
that kind of looks
like this, where
you have a lot of stuff
that's really well crushed--
hopefully you have a lot of
that-- and then some stuff
that was poorly crushed.
And so what you
need to do is grab
the stuff that was poorly
crushed and crush it.
The super crushed fine
stuff acts as a sponge
to dampen the act of
crushing everything else,
so it's pretty annoying.
So there is not enough
ag waste in the world
to solve the needs of
fuel usage in the world.
However, there is enough to have
it be one part of the solution,
and then different
areas will have
different amounts of ag waste.
So places that have no
farming, obviously, you're
not going to have any ag
waste and it's inappropriate.
Places where there are
farming, some people
use their ag waste either
to feed their cattle
or to replenish the
soil or to light
the fires to process the
sugar juice that they
dispose of the sugar cane.
In all those areas, you
can't use this process.
But there are many areas
where the ag waste is just
sitting in rotting.
And I'll get into
this on Friday,
but that makes methane gas,
which is a worse greenhouse
gas than the stuff
we're emitting
by doing that nasty
process in the oil drum.
So that we're doing the
environmental credit
by not letting it rot and
making something that is useful.
All right, that's not
boiling, but it's pretty hot,
so we're going to go with
it and see what happens.
So you can see on the
sheet the directions.
There's a ratio
for how much binder
or how much cassava to how
much water to how many--
to an oil drums
worth of charcoal.
And there's a bunch of different
methods for using cassava.
So the easiest is just
grating it and dumping it.
But that means you're using
up all the food to cook with.
So another option is to squeeze
out the grated material,
and you can do that
with a cheesecloth.
But it's pretty
juicy, so you can
see you do get some liquid
out, but it's not a great rate
because a lot of it is the meat.
But anyway, so you can
take those squeezings
and just use that
as your binder,
and then save the
meat to cook with.
And you can make a really great
cassava cake with the meat,
among other things.
So in terms of the
ratio, the measurements
are done in milliliters, which
is a little ridiculous when
you're in the field.
And so the other
rule of thumb is
that a yuca about the
size that I showed you
is right for one oil
drum, fully grated.
But if you're doing the
squeeze method then,
you need to use more
cassava because you're
getting a whole lot less out.
And then, you put
the cassava in,
and you want to do it while it's
boiling because the starch goes
through a transition.
It's much like making candy.
So you get your
sugar hot enough,
and then it gets
into a caramel state.
So we're getting to the
caramel state of yuca.
It can get kind of clumpy,
so you want to stir it,
and then once it's been
boiling for a bit and stirring,
you take it off, and
hopefully, what you
have is snot-like consistency.
Yuca is what you
get tapioca from,
so we're basically making
a very unprocessed version
of tapioca pudding.
It doesn't taste nearly as good.
So now we need to mix
this with the charcoal.
So there's a five gallon bucket
that's gray on the table.
If you can grab that.
So you can see, most of this
charcoal is well-crushed.
The diameter of charcoal that
you're going for is bigger--
this is a snot-like is one
of those classic measurements
that everyone in the
world can understand.
This is one that you
can only understand
if you go to Trader
Joe's, so it's
on the opposite end of
the useful spectrum,
but wasabi covered pea.
So I'm eyeballing
all these ratios
because I've been
doing this for a while,
but this is the kind
of thing that you
do want to actually
follow directions.
If there's not enough binder,
it'll be pretty obvious--
a little more-- because
it won't stick together.
But if there's too much, it
makes smoky briquettes, again,
because it's
uncarbonized material.
And then it's really important,
before you start briquetting,
to make sure you mix
everything, like making a cake,
where if you have a bunch of
flour left over at the end,
that stinks.
So you don't want any
charcoal powder left over.
And another thing to notice
is that the binder now
is really hot.
I think we're probably good.
And so if you mix
this with your hand--
and it's actually easier to
mix by hand than with anything
else--
you'll burn your hand,
and it's like hot glue
in that once it's on, it's
really hard to get off.
So those are my tips to you
for making this more pleasant.
So we have a few
different designs
of our [INAUDIBLE] press.
So I'll talk about
this more on Friday,
but this is a really simple nice
device that you can basically
make anywhere for about $2.
So the way it works is it's
three pieces, a bottom pusher
piece, a cup, and
then a top plunger.
So you load the
material into the cup,
and you can just do that
directly with your hand.
You can put it in anything where
this part can rest on something
and the center part
doesn't get pushed up.
So we have these wood
blocks, but you can usually
find a cement brick will work,
or put two pieces of table
together, or whatever.
There's lots of options.
And then can I have a hammer?
And then you put the plunger on,
you give it a few good whacks,
and then you just pop
this out on the side
to make your briquette.
The charcoal will
build up right here,
and so every so often,
you have to clean it off.
You'll also notice
as you're doing this
that a lot of
charcoal gets wasted.
And so it's smart
to actually do this
on some of tarp or
rice bag or something
so you can capture the charcoal.
And you usually waste
enough charcoal to make
a few briquettes, and it's
painful to waste that charcoal.
So once the briquettes
are made, they
need to dry in the
sun for a few days,
and then you can cook with them.
However, if you want them to
be really sturdy so that they
can handle being
transported to market,
they can kind of get crumbly.
And so what you can do is
the next use for chicken wire
is to make a basket like this
that holds your briquettes.
And then right before
you put the lid on,
you can throw this
into the drum.
And it's totally ridiculous,
but you managed to do it
and it works so that these
don't actually light on fire,
they just get hot enough to--
well, not just to
dry, because you do
have to dry them
in the sun first,
but then they get hot
enough that the starch goes
through yet another
phase transition.
So when you're thinking
about making candy,
it goes from the caramel
stage to the hard candy stage.
So you get to the
hard candy stage,
and then you have
hard briquettes.
So if that's important to
whoever is making them--
if you're making them
for use at your house,
it doesn't matter at all.
If you're making
them for use to sell,
then you probably
want to do this stage.
And you can make a
bunch of these bags
and just throw them in, but
I just have one for show.
So if people want
to help, though,
but before we take off this
brick, we should get as much
of the sand off as possible.
There's actually this,
which helps a lot,
but you rarely
have in the field.
Yeah, you can do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I was, like,
hugging it for the whole hour.
AMY BANZAERT: So you can see
that it's pretty well black,
and when you break it apart,
it's black on the inside.
So it's kind of nasty.
AUDIENCE: It's so
nasty, like burny.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Burny?
Yeah.
So good job.
When you are getting this
out, what usually works well
is to dump it on its side, being
kind of careful that not too
much falls out of the bottom.
And then you can tip it and
empty it into your rice bag,
and then, oftentimes,
you have to reach in
to scoop out the
last bits, which
is a little unpleasant
but not too bad.
So actually, yeah, it would
be good to do that now.
Yeah, it would.
So we need to get the
rest of the sand off,
and then we can do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: It's easier
if you just get it all off.
All right, so
that's pretty good.
We're not we're not looking
for zero particles of sand,
just not too, too many.
AUDIENCE: So that way?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
So we should tilt it over?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
AMY BANZAERT: Do you
have it over the hole?
It's still hot.
[CLANG]